-This movie -- I know
everybody was very worried
that it would not make
any money.
-Yeah. People were
very concerned.
-They were very concerned.
-It was a little indie movie
But word of mouth is spreading
to the tune of $1 billion!
-And this is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look.
This is an incredible cast
A lot of our dear friends
are in this film.
-Yes.
-Beyoncé is in this film.
-One of our dearest friends.
-Dearest friends.
Who is coming tonight?
Maybe she didn't.
I can't remember.
-Oh, okay.
-She always likes to watch
from the audience.
-She likes to surprise
with a ten-minute set
at the Comedy Store...
-Yeah.
-...and then come.
-But "Entertainment Weekly
said there's a clear
standout performance
in "The Lion King,"
and it's not Beyoncé.
They fully give you
the standout performance.
-Yeah, that's very --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes. All right. Thank you.
Except with a headline
like that, I literally,
because of Beyoncé, have to join
the witness protection program
-Yeah.
-You know?
Which didn't stop me
from retweeting it, by the way
But, still --
No, it's very nice.
The reception
has been really amazing.
-Let's talk Oscar buzz,
because there has yet to b
anyone nominated
for voice work, right?
-I didn't realize this,
but no one has ever
been nominated
for a voice performance ever
in any acting category.
-I feel like this is --
Like, what better year
to get it started, right?
-Well, I agree with you, Seth.
Look, you know,
I'm just a simple, ordinary ma
with an Emmy nom and Oscar buzz,
trying to make it in our
cruel and unforgiving world.
-My fingers are crossed for you.
-Fingers are crossed.
-You had a premiere.
And you got to meet --
You can see right there.
You got to meet Meghan Markle.
-Yep.
-There she is right there.
-And Prince Harry.
-Prince Harry.
-That's me and Seth Rogen.
-But you and Meghan Markle
you went to college together
Same school I went to.
-Same school you went to. Yeah
Meghan Markle and I went
to Northwestern together,
and we were both theater majors,
and we didn't --
[ Scattered cheers ]
Okay, we get it.
We were both theater majors.
Go, Cats. I love Northwestern.
We were both theater majors, and
we were there at the same time
We didn't know each other.
But in the midst of all
this pomp and circumstance
and at that premiere --
Literally, we're in a row,
a receiving line with
Prince Harry, Meghan Markle,
Beyoncé, Elton John, Pharrell,
Tim Rice, all these people
Me, obviously.
And in the middle of all that,
Meghan and I are having
a very casual conversation
about who our acting teacher
were at Northwestern.
And she said, "Congratulations
on your career."
And I said, "Congratulations
And she said,
"Well, it took a little turn."
[ Laughter ]
But she had
a great sense of humor.
And they were lovely,
very down-to-earth.
-That's great.
So you got to watch it with them
and all the people
you mentioned,
but you have also tried
to see it with
a regular audience, as well.
-Yes. I did. We had two
premieres. And that's fun.
There are celebrities
and industry people.
But I wanted to see it
with regular moviegoers.
-Yeah. And kids.
It must be fun.
-It's a movie for children
and for families ultimately.
So I went to see it in IMAX.
I snuck into a regular screening
in IMAX in L.A.
over the weekend,
which was beautiful.
The movie looks incredible
It's so beautiful-looking.
But, you know,
I haven't been to a movie
where a lot of children ar
in a long time.
So basically, it's parents
spending a hundred dollars
to take their kids to the
bathroom, is what I reali-
It's like -- So against
the beautiful "Lion King"
for two hours
is a silhouette of childre
being dragged up and down
the stairs to the bathroom
for like two hours.
I was like, "Why are the parents
paying for this?"
-Yeah.
-But I enjoyed it.
You know, it's a nice movie.
-And you had a connection to
"The Lion King" on Broadway.
-Yes.
-As an actor, people might not
know your connection to
"The Lion King" on Broadway.
-Yes. This is a true story
I was a bartender
at "The Lion King" on Broadway
when I was a struggling actor,
still struggling,
according to some critics.
But when I was
a struggling actor,
I was a bartender
at Broadway shows.
And you know it's a bad sign -
I was a bartender
at one theater,
and then they moved me
to "The Lion King,"
which means I'm a bad bartender.
Because no one's making martinis
at "The Lion King," right?
So basically, you're selling
candy and soda the whole time.
And in a foreshadowing
of my later career,
where I have to shout a lot,
my job during intermission
was to shout over all the kids
in the lobby,
"All food, water, and soda can
be brought into the theater!
That was my job, was to
make sure the parents knew
if they bought things,
their kids could continue
to eat them
during act two, yeah.
-Speaking of kids and food
you're a Happy Meal toy.
-I am a Happy Meal toy.
-You're merchandise.
That's very exciting.
First time merchandised.
-Aww. Isn't that nice?
You can eat that
while getting a heart attack
at the same time.
Yes, that's fun. Who knew
I'd be a Happy Meal toy?
-Happy Meal,
and you mentioned
you are nominated for an Emm
for "Billy on the Street."
-I am.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
-How do you feel
about your chances?
-I mean, I'm pretty sure
I'm going to lose to
freaking "Carpool Karaoke.
-Yeah, it's a juggernaut.
-They're in every cat--
I love -- I've been
on "Carpool Karaoke."
-You have, yes.
-I literally did it.
I did "Carpool Karaoke" with
Metallica, which is actually -
Don't clap, okay?
Because now
they're my competition.
But, no, I feel like I'm going
to lose to "Carpool Karaoke.
But, you know, maybe not.
-Yeah.
-Maybe on the wind
of my Oscar buzz...
-Yes, that's true. That's true
'Cause sometimes Emmy voters
are like, "You know what?
We could be, like,
Oscar-adjacent with our vote."
-Right. Exactly. So we'll see.
"Carpool Karaoke"
has like 30 Emmy --
They're in every category!
-Yes.
-"Carpool Karaoke"
is nominated for, like,
Best Supporting Actress.
I'm not kidding.
Somehow -- I don't know wh
we're promoting
your stiffest competition.
He's on right now, if you
want to change the channel
-But come right back. Go say h
and then come right back.
Thanks so much for being here.
It's always great to have you.
That's Billy Eichner, everybody.